[Música]
hoy nuestro negocio familiar cumple
nueve años
hace unos meses pensamos que este día no
iba a llegar como todo el mundo el 2020
nos agarró completamente por sorpresa de
la noche a la mañana estábamos viviendo
en una película de miedo todo lo que
proyectamos todo lo que planificamos se
vino abajo en días como muchos de
ustedes dijimos no esto seguramente va a
durar un mes sin embargo las semanas
pasaron y pasaron y el panorama
simplemente fue empeorando con la
restricción vehicular- los clientes no
nos podían visitar con las fronteras
cerradas la mercadería no puede ingresar
sin clientes sin mercadería no iban a
ver ventas por más de que les digamos
punta al lápiz los números
matemáticamente no daban y todo se
empezó a complicar las planillas los
alquileres los bancos llegará el próximo
mes era una tarea que simplemente
parecía imposible
esto por supuesto me dolía a nivel
laboral ahí justo en mi ego profesional
pero además me dolía era mi corazón
nuestro negocio familiar fue fundado por
mi mamá hace más de 30 años en la sala
de nuestra casa con nosotras tres sus
hijas así de chiquititas
lo hizo crecer a tal punto que el sueño
se convirtió en el nuestro ya que hace
unos años yo decidí denunciar a mi mundo
de carrera corporativa a esa proyección
laboral exitosa y estable para sumarme a
este barco era el sueño de ella era el
sueño mío el de mi papá el de mi hermana
el de un equipo grande era mucha la
gente que dependía de esto pero entonces
me pregunto cómo es que hemos logrado
seguir a flote y realmente sólo
encuentro una explicación el propósito
detrás del propósito como cualquier
negocio nuestro propósito por supuesto
es generar utilidades sin embargo la
diferencia está en el propósito detrás
del propósito desde el día uno en igea
tigre hemos grupo hemos procurado y
hemos luchado para inspirar a todas las
mujeres en poder haré las recordarles
que son increíbles por fuera un ejemplo
de esto es que aún en una pandemia
mundial hicimos una plataforma para
ellas para nosotras en colaboración con
nuestra amiga de vino a con la pandemia
sé que todas nosotras empezamos a sentir
emociones que no nos hacían sentir muy
bien miedo incertidumbre
soledad tristeza
nosotros simplemente dijimos no nos
podemos quedar de brazos cruzados y fue
ahí donde bautizamos nuestro proyecto
círculos 3 y 33 una plataforma virtual
para dar herramientas de inspiración a
todas las mujeres que decidieron ser
parte de ella esto lo hacíamos
semanalmente a través de artículos de
vídeo de información de tips pero
también a través de un evento virtual o
ciertos eventos virtuales pequeñitos
llamados círculos virtuales ha sido muy
especial como en estos círculos hemos
podido presenciar que en un mismo
espacio virtual está conectado una mujer
desde guanacaste y una de filipinas en
donde hemos abordado temas demasiado
relevantes para nosotras salud femenina
en esta salud hormonal cáncer de mama
emprendimiento femenino feminismo
hemos podido presenciar como en un mismo
círculo una mujer de 17 años y una de 70
años han podido compartir sus
experiencias lo que sienten
definitivamente estos más de 1500
mujeres todas somos diferentes pero
compartimos una cosa sabemos que no
estamos solas y que estamos juntas en
esto
definitivamente cuando hago una pausa y
analizo lo que he aprendido este año lo
que he vivido este año logro entender
que vivir bajo el propósito detrás del
propósito no sólo impacta a mi vida
laboral sino también mi vida personal ya
que analizo en retrospectiva cuáles han
sido esos momentos de mi vida donde he
estado más perdida sin encontrar el
rumbo y han sido momentos donde estaba
más desconectada de mi propósito
auténtico es ahí donde me doy cuenta que
realmente lo que importa no es lo que yo
haga todos los días sino por qué lo hago
realmente creo que al menos en mi caso y
me atrevería a decir que el de mi
generación
que cuestiona nuestro propósito es más
relevante hoy que nunca esta pandemia
mundial nos hizo recordar que nada está
en nuestro control pero que al mismo
tiempo una pequeña acción que ejecutemos
puede cambiar el curso de una pandemia y
por qué no de la vida misma aquí hoy en
costa rica en mi vida y como efecto
dominó en la vida de todo el mundo en la
vida del mundo si así lo queremos pensar
realmente ha sido un año donde
pues si realmente creo creo en esto pero
al mismo tiempo aunque esté hoy aquí
hablando de un tema que me apasiona
tanto como lo es el propósito ha sido el
año en donde más que ningún otro momento
en mi vida he pensado que no estoy
haciendo las cosas bien que no soy
suficiente que no va lo suficiente que
que no lo voy a lograr y realmente han
sido esos espacios donde me he quebrado
donde he sido vulnerable donde ha
abierto este espacio para conversar
conmigo misma y de verme al espejo y
decir melissa me conecte con el
propósito detrás de su propósito y ese
pequeño momento esa pausa me permite
tomar un respiro y decir ok voy por buen
camino y no me malentiendan yo realmente
estoy demasiado agradecida con todo lo
que lo que pasa en mi vida sé que tengo
muchas bendiciones y que todas estas
dificultades realmente son pocas
comparado a la vida de otras personas
sé que independientemente de que estemos
en un punto alto de nuestra vida o en un
punto bajo de que haya pandemia o no si
vivimos conectados con la filosofía de
el propósito detrás del propósito sólo
cosas buenas pueden aparecer a nuestra
vida el mundo está pidiendo a gritos
cambios y somos nosotros los
responsables de ser los agentes de
cambio de estos cambios y realmente lo
vamos a lograr de una forma exitosa solo
si estamos conectados con un propósito
de realmente genuino sé más que nunca
que hoy en día necesitamos mujeres y
seres humanos conectados con un
propósito noble con un propósito detrás
de un propósito
[Música]